let's talk about porn Google Glasses
which we've also been talking about a
lot lately so they're coming and it is
going to change privacy the way we know
what we're all gonna be walking around
recording everything every time you look
at somebody you can snap a picture of
them Anthony Weiner is gonna love this
thing but the first porn videos are on
their way being shot with Google Glasses
X biz and me kandi have come out with a
little trailer this is a comedy porn
trailer for what their porn will look
like let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
you technicon hi this is so much better
giving up tips maybe I should have said
NSFW before that video but okay anyway
so yeah that is going to be the future
of porn it's very obvious you're gonna
see it it's all gonna come right out of
your eyes that sounded weird anywho are
you excited about the future of porn is
the is the third-person camera it's -
we've all seen it already you want a
Google glass on your face and get right
up in it I think maybe because this was
like you said a comedic version of what
will be yes don't really know exactly
what it is gonna be I'm still missing it
and I picture those people naked can you
picture that this is not the porn part
right I would like supposed to be
looking at the genitalia I mean you
really can't figure out what this is
gonna be like and of course this is
prerecorded soul as a person looking at
wherever they want to look and this
again these are logistics that inquiring
minds would like to know yeah but also
and in the funny part of it I think was
you know he checked out our shoes and he
said oh you can get these for different
rights all these things that was that
was the best part of it I thought right
so in those Woollett link - oh yeah the
Saints say a woman is watching the porn
because I like that uh that lingerie set
and actually doesn't look at it and you
will look it up and you will be able to
buy it so porn is gonna truly become a
multitasking thing because porn right
now is one thing all right you'll be
able to sell stuff I want to be selling
butt plugs right learn right during the
porn thing that's the first time we've
said butt plugs on the case aren't you
proud of me Dad
so the Google glass thing just in
general yeah I am not wanting this for
our culture and I do not want this I am
afraid of it we were talking TiVo
earlier just how that changed our life I
was at a big event a big YouTube event
guy was walking around with the googoo
glasses
all I kept saying all night was who's
the [ __ ] in the Google glasses which
he then recorded it up where he probably
did but this is not good this is not
okay I'm not happy with this stop okay
so let's we'll get back to the porn part
in a second but let's follow that for a
little bit so yes I completely agree I
don't even think we
even the slightest grasp on how deeply
this is gonna change how humans interact
in two years from now if we're all
wearing these we're gonna be recording
everything constantly there will be no
private conversations I mean we've
already lost half of that between NSA
and all that stuff that's something else
altogether
what's your general thoughts on the
Google glass this idea of everything
being recorded and uploaded and tracked
and just I'm thinking everything I've we
just want our cell phones think about
the the evolution of a cell phone
I remember just in college and I
graduated no to our first full and still
had the green screen they're the size
that's why I stood them open yeah and
just where it's grown since then in
these eleven years and where this is
this the base version this is the
archaic version of Google glasses and
what's on it next you know you have
people with their phones filming people
without them knowing it up skirts and
all that stuff putting on their toes and
walking under women this is all I mean
so with just glasses on your face people
just wear dark sunglasses you don't know
where their eyes are right so when this
goes they're recording now whatever it
is and we're basically creating a matrix
we're creating the matrix the movie the
matrix that's what we're creating we're
all recording everything constantly
we're creating this alternate digital
world and who's gonna control it and own
it and I'm hoping this'll help us all
learn to say no to this just rampant
progressive technology that we're not
getting to vote on we're not getting to
decide how its effect how it like the
long term 2 5 10 20 years out this stuff
exponentially you know progresses in an
incredible way we need to stop saying no
to some of this stuff and just yes it's
cool fine but just because it's cool
doesn't mean it's gonna help us survive
as a species this is all of us
ultimately becoming those fat people in
wall-e remember the movie wall-e
where we all end up in these chairs and
we order our big soda and this is Mike
Bloomberg's nightmare baby yeah but III
agree with you and I don't I don't know
is there has there ever been a
technology that's been given to us or
created or invented that we didn't use
you mean anything that's ever made it
taste really
that's the one because they were quality
better than everything else we rejected
them for some reason
exactly no but really besides beta yeah
that is really the only I mean
everything if we come up with the
technology to create a nuclear bomb we
do drop it yeah I mean is there anything
that we I mean that's sort of just what
humanity is and maybe that's why
ultimately we're gonna destroy ourselves
one day because we just can't stack
society and imagine if you now say when
who has a smartphone
98% of population maybe that's too high
of a number I'd go 80 a lot of people
I'm with 80 but the thing is when you
see someone if they walk down shoot with
the Nokia square brick phone yes you
gotta make fun of them to their face
you're gonna go [ __ ] is this guy Carrie
it is so now everybody's watching with
their Google glasses in ten years and
their Google super glasses plus and you
don't have anything on your face and you
look at there's one with you and you got
to go get it because this the the Google
store down the street
just let us just release this new this
new promotion
- oh you loopy hundred dollars and it's
actually a thousand after ten years
rest of it off yeah everybody you have
to have it now or else you're losing all
right I don't believe in a god but I
will pray to God we don't turn our
culture into this you will pray to the
thing you don't believe that's how upset
I am about these things yeah yeah all
right well let's bring it back to porn
for one second here so you know Google
has already said that they're not gonna
have porn apps in their App Store so me
candy I think that's a that's an Android
app store that's gonna deal with the
porn stuff but why is it that these
companies are so anti pornhub we don't
expect morals to come from my technology
companies like Apple and Samsung and
Google but yet they feel the need to
block that stuff instead of just letting
us click a box saying I'm over 18 it is
interesting because the porn industry
has always been the leadership in new
technology they with VHS tapes they
changed you know a partially killed beta
pretty much yeah you know and everything
the internet they were leaders in the
internet and I didn't kill masturbator
so it is interesting but I think it is
these these technology companies saying
you know no we want a guide you know we
want to be in charge of how we control
the minds of the future but is it more
they ready some moral stand here it's an
interesting moral stand knee-jerk
Society Oh penis remember we talked
about the whole conversation James for
news because Anthony Weiner's penis is
back and yes so soon if it's anything
with sex you have to go well we don't
have anything to do with sex because you
know that would disparage our reputation
because America is we don't have sex in
America everything we do we hide it so
in doing that if you're from with it
you're gonna be considered you know
there's a bunch of dirty names for you
you know you're a smut peddler yeah you
know so smut peddlers cannot be
associated with this technology company
we're doing this for informational
purposes we're Google we're doing
something lofty and good here for
humanity you've got to have government
regulation on board to do whatever they
want with their technology and as we
know there's a lot of people in
government these days who have a lot to
say about bodies you know a lot of the
people in the right wing don't want
anything to do with bodies and smut and
women and all of that and and I think
it's a general also just thinking about
it how disconnected we are from our
bodies anyway and technology disconnects
you even more that it's kind of
interesting that they're like we don't
even want you connecting to like the
most basic thing about your body with
our technology and just wait you know
we're in the middle of this Weiner Gator
right now I mean just wait he was doing
it on Twitter but you know time will
come when somebody on Google Glasses
there's gonna be a girl
kneeling beneath some senator looking up
at there that'll be exciting to see your
Senators penis on a Google glass yeah
cause he's signing some bill that he'd
never read you know him you know I read
the barrel and then when whips they get
hacked Google glass and someone someone
down the street is now got your eyesight
yeah
you
[Music]